take a minute and think of yourself as
the leader of a country and let's say
one of your biggest priorities is to
provide your citizens with high quality
health care how would you go about it
build more hospitals open more medical
colleges invest into little innovation
but what if your country's health system
was fundamentally broken whether its
doctor absenteeism drug stock outs or
poor quality of care where would you
start then I am a management consultant
and for the last three years I've been
working on a project to improve the
public health system of Rajasthan a
state in India and during the course of
the project we actually discovered
something profound more doctors better
facilities clinical innovation they are
all important but nothing changes
without one key ingredient motivation
but motivations are tricky think if
you've led a team raised a child or
tried to change a personal habit you
know what that motivation doesn't just
appear something has to change to make
you care and if there's one thing that
all of us humans care about it's an
inherent desire to shine in front of
society so that's exactly what we did we
decided to focus on the citizen the
people who the system was supposed to
serve in the first place and today I'd
like to tell you how Rajasthan has
transformed its public health system
dramatically by using the citizen to
trigger motivation now Rajasthan is one
of India's largest states with a
population of nearly 80 million
that's larger than the United Kingdom
but the similarities probably end there
in 2016 when my team was called in to
start working with the public health
system of Rajasthan we found it in a
state of crisis for example the neonatal
mortality rate that's the number of
newborns who died before their first
month birthday was 10 times higher than
that of the UK no wonder then that
citizens were saying hey I don't want to
go to a public health facility in India
if you wanted to see a doctor in a
public health facility you would go to a
pH C or primary health center and at
least 40 patients are expected to go to
a PHC every day but in Rajasthan only
one out of four pH sees were seeing this
minimum number of patients in other
words people had lost faith in the
system when we delved deeper we realized
that lack of accountability is at the
core of it picture this Suda a daily
wage earner realizes that her
one-year-old daughter is suffering from
uncontrollable this entry so she decides
to take the day off that's a loss of
about 350 rupees or 5 dollars and she
picks up her daughter in her arms and
walks for five kilometres to the
government be at sea but the doctor
isn't there so she takes the next day
off again and comes back to the PHC this
time the doctor is there but the
pharmacist tells her that the free drugs
that she's entitled to have run out
because they forgot to reorder them on
time so now she rushes to the private
medical center and as she's rushing
they're looking at her daughter's
condition worsening with every passing
hour she can't help but wonder if she
should have gone to the private medical
center in the first place
and paid 350 rupees for the consultation
and drugs
no one is held accountable for this
incredible failure of the system costing
time money and heartache D'Souza and
this is something that just had to be
fixed now as all good consultants we
decided that data-driven reviews had to
be the answer to improve accountability
so we created these fancy performance
dashboards to help make the review
meetings of the health department much
more effective but nothing changed
discussion after discussion meeting
after meeting nothing changed and that's
when it struck me you see public systems
have always been governed through
internal mechanisms like review meetings
and over time their accountability to
the citizen has been diluted so why not
bring the citizen back into the equation
perhaps by using a citizen promises
couldn't that trigger motivation we
started with what I like to call the
coffee-shop strategy you've probably
seen one of these signs in a coffee shop
which says if you don't get your receipt
the coffee is free now
the cashier has no option but to give
you a receipt each time so we took this
strategy and applied it to Rajasthani we
worked with the government on a program
to revive 300 PhDs across the state and
we caught them to paint very clear
citizen promises along the wall we
assure you that you will have a doctor
each time we assure you that you will
get your free drugs each time we assure
you
you'll get your free Diagnostics each
time and finally we worked with elected
representatives to launch these revived
PLC's who shared the citizen promises
with the community with a lot of fanfare
now the promise was out there in the
open
failure would be embarrassing the system
had to start delivering and deliver it
did doctor availability went up
medicines came on hand and as a result
patient visits went up by 20% in less
than a year the Public Health System was
getting back into business but there was
still a long distance to go change isn't
that easy
an accesory rated doctor once told me I
really want to transform the maternal
health in my community brightest don't
have enough nurses now resources like
nurses are actually controlled by
administrative officers who the doctor
is report to and while the doctors were
now motivated the administrative
officers simply weren't motivated enough
to help the doctors this is where the
head of the Public Health Department
Miss vino Gupta came up with a brilliant
idea a monthly ranking of all districts
and this ranking would assess the
performance of every district on each
major disease and each major procedure
but here's the best part
we made the ranking go public we put the
ranking on the website we put the
ranking on social media and before you
knew it the media got involved with
newspaper articles on which districts
were doing well and which ones weren't
and we didn't just want the district the
rankings to impact the best and the
worst performing districts we wanted the
rankings to motivate every district so
we took inspiration from soccer leagues
and created a three-tiered ranking
system whereby every quarter
if a districts performance were to
decline you could get relegated to the
lower tier but if the district's
performance were to improve you could
get promoted to the Premier League the
rankings were a big success it generated
tremendous excitement and districts
began vying with each other to be known
as exemplars it's actually very simple
if you think about it if the performance
data is only being reviewed by your
manager in internal settings it it
simply isn't motivating enough but if
that data is out there in the open for
the community to see that's a very
different picture that just unlocks a
competitive spirit which is inherent in
each and every one of us so now when you
put these two together the coffee-shop
strategy and public competition
you now had a public health system which
was significantly more motivated to
improve citizen health and now that you
had a more motivated health system it
was actually a system that was now much
more ready for support because now there
is a pull for the support whether it's
resources data or skill building let me
share an example I was once at a
district meeting in the district of
Ajmer this is one of the districts that
have been rising rapidly in the rankings
and there were a group of passionate
doctors who were discussing ideas on how
to better support their teams one of the
doctors held up skilled health workers
to tackle the problem of nurse shortages
another doctor was using whatsapp in
creative ways to share information and
ideas with his frontline workers for
example where are the children who are
missing from immunization and how do you
convince the mothers to actually bring
their children for immunization
and because their teams were now
significantly motivated they were simply
lapping up the support because they
wanted to perform better and better
broken systems certainly need more
resources and tools but they won't drive
much impact if you don't first address
the motivation challenge once the
motivation tide begins to shift that's
when you get the real returns of
resources and tools but I still haven't
answered a key question what happened to
the performance of Rajasthan public
health system in 2016 when our work
began the government of India and the
World Bank came out with a public health
index Rajasthan was ranked 20th out of
21 large states but in 2018 when the
next ranking came out Rajasthan showed
one of the highest improvements among
all lot states in India leapfrogging for
positions for example it showed one of
the highest reductions in neonatal
mortality with 3,000 additional newborn
lives being saved every year typically
public health transformations take a
long time even decades but this approach
had delivered results in two years but
here's the best part there is actually
nothing rajasthan specific about what we
learned in fact this approach of using
the citizen to trigger motivation is not
even limited to public health systems I
sincerely believe that if there is any
public system in any country that is in
inertia then we need to bring back the
motivation and a great way to trigger
the motivation is to increase
transparency to the citizen
we can do this with education and
sanitation and even political
representation government schools can
compete publicly on the basis of student
enrollment cities and towns on the basis
of cleanliness and politicians on the
basis of a scorecard of how exactly
they're improving citizen lives there
are many broken systems out there in the
world we need to bring back their
motivation the citizen is waiting we
must act today thank you very much
[Applause]